[Music]
so
um this your first time in New York
should we be asking each other
that have you ever killed
anyone no no no not really really no
where do I begin to tell the story of
how great love can be you're married the
Sweet Love Story is old I should be
clear I'm not in this for the
[Music]
romance what is it that you two
do we're computer uh software and
Engineers he fil my
heart with very speci things with Ang s
with wild I should be dead he FS my soul
with so much love
anywhere how's the intimacy between the
two of
you I'm scared
could I reach
for it's
there what do you think happens if we
fail our marriage our
mission and he will
be
[Music]
there